hier bei novo nordisk wird an der
zukunft der diabetesbehandlung geforscht
an spritzen wie man die tabletten
einnehmen kann zb diabetes gehört ja zu
den häufigsten chronischen krankheiten
auf der welt und die erkrankungen werden
sich weltweit in den nächsten 30 jahren
fast verdoppeln und die behandlung der
zukunft die wird spektakulär wie das
werde ich heute im rahmen der vfh
kampagne forschung ist die beste medizin
hier bei novo nordisk erfahren vfa ist
der verband der forschenden
pharma-unternehmen tricks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes science videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasste nicht
herzlich willkommen herzlich willkommen
diabetes ist nicht gleich diabetes es
gibt typ 1 und typ 2 beide krankheiten
bedeuten dass der zucker im blut falsch
regulierte typ 1 können dabei schon
kinder und jugendliche bekommen
dieser typ wird durch eine
autoimmunerkrankung ausgelöst das heißt
der körper bildet antikörper gegen den
eigenen körper beziehungsweise zählen
die er zur existenz benötigt in diesem
fall werden die eigenen beta zellen
angegriffen und zerstört der körper
produziert so kein insulin mehr es muss
als medikament gegeben werden denn
ansonsten würde der zucker nicht
verarbeitet werden und in das gewebe
gelangen wo er als energielieferant
gebraucht wird ein ähnlicher effekt
tritt auch bei diabetes typ 2 auf
allerdings ist es hier keine
autoimmunerkrankung sondern vor allem
falsche ernährung übergewicht oder zum
beispiel auch mangelnde bewegung sind
hier auslöser der erkrankung bisher war
das mittel der wahl ein pen mit dem man
sich mit einer spitze
das benötigte insulin selbst spritzt für
viele eine sehr unangenehme prozedur
doch als tablette kann insulin bisher
nicht eingenommen werden bisher dr
markus schindler ist leiter der
medikamentenforschung bei novo nordisk
wir haben jetzt seit fünf jahren eine
sehr interessante kooperation mit einem
forscherteam am massachusetts institute
of technology mit und mit dieser gruppe
das sind engine ingenieure mit denen
haben wir zusammen arbeitet um
neue kapsel zu entwickeln und das
interessante an dieser kapseln sind
erstmal zwei dinge die sie enthält im
prinzip eine eine nadel und diese nadel
ist aus insulin hergestellt und diese
nadel ins er initiiert im prinzip das
insulin in die magenschleimhaut es wird
also eine spritze geschluckt spannend
ist natürlich auch wie können wir
sicherstellen dass sich diese nadel
wirklich in die magenschleimhaut
einsticht und wie können wir
sicherstellen dass es immer wieder
passiert und da haben wir also eine
inspiration genommen an in der natur
diese kleine kapsel hat die form eines
schildkrötenpanzer es gibt eine
afrikanische schildkröte die hat diesen
diese panzer form und warum ist es
wichtig für die schildkröte es bedeutet
einfach egal wo diese schildkröte
hinfällt sie wird sich immer wieder im
prinzip auf ihrem bauch wieder auf ihren
füßen sogar wieder hin was ist was man
will und man findet das immer wieder in
derselben orientierung wieder einfach
aber genial allerdings es wird noch
mindestens zehn jahre dauern bis diese
kapsel auf den markt kommt noch sind die
finalen materialien nicht bestimmt noch
ist nicht klar ob garantiert jede kapsel
auch immer zuverlässig funktioniert noch
müssen zahlreiche klinische tests
gemacht werden und das dauert aber es
geht noch weiter in zukunft soll es
intelligentes insulin geben was nach der
gabe noch auf den blutzucker reagiert
und ihn nur abbaut wenn zu viel im blut
ist das heißt sie gehen am dieses
molekül ran ich sag mal
man darf es als komplex verzeichnen und
wollen das so verändern dass da ist mein
element reinkommt was detektieren kann
wie viel zucker im blut ist und demnach
entscheidet ob es in aktion tritt oder
nicht wie geht denn so was
wir werden im prinzip das insulin
molekül nehmen und bauen einen
chemischen blutzucker sensor an dieses
molekül an dass es auch auf molekularer
ebene
dieser sensor wird feststellen wie viel
zucker im blut zu einem gegebenen
zeitpunkt ist und verändert dann das
insulin molekül entweder in eine
aktive oder in eine aktive form insofern
entscheidet das insulin molekül
sozusagen selber das aktive also das
hört sich danach an als würden sie
nobelpreis kriegen wenn sie persönlich
vermutlich nicht aber ich denke die
forscher die darauf arbeiten dass eine
kooperation auch mit englischen
forschungseinheit angegangen haben das
sind sicherlich die großen durchbrüche
in der diabetestherapie die wir uns die
wir uns alle auf und hier wird noch
einen schritt weitergegangen im
stammzellen labor werden beta zellen
gezüchtet die dann wieder im körper
insulin produzieren können die kollegen
peter zu klumpen sozusagen unter dem
mikroskop besitzt ungefähr so kunden
1.000 später zählen und wie sie braucht
man dann für patienten also das ist im
augenblick noch schwierig zu sagen aber
wir gehen davon aus dass ungefähr eine
milliarde zellen oder mehr wird für
einen einzelnen patienten was auch
bedeutet dass ein großer teil unserer
forschung dahin geht im prinzip diese
zellen im industriellen maßstab
heranzuzüchten unter
in großen behältern
zu vermehren und das ist natürlich eine
große aufgabe auf die qualität zu
sichern ich bin extrem gespannt in
zukunft darüber zu berichten wie all
diese projekte realität werden
unangenehme nebenwirkungen hat übrigens
auch ums dicke eier mal anders ein video
von medizinstudenten anklicken anschauen
und natürlich den kanal abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran